have someone joining us to show us how
we can make a french baguette
at home welcome lizzy heaps the food
nanny now i i when you said bread i'm
all in but a baguette that's a whole new
level tell us a little bit about what
you got going on there
well we love bread we feel like we're
the queen of bread
so we love to show all different kind of
breads but
we have a french baguette from start to
finish only takes
30 minutes which is pretty incredible
because
other recipes it's a 24 hour process so
i love to whip this up for lunches for
dinner it's the fastest easiest bread
you will ever do
okay so show us how we can get this and
i had no idea we could make it that
quickly
how do we do that okay so so fast so
i've already had my yeast that's been
going wow look how good that looks
so we're going to add this is a half a
cup of water and one and a half
tablespoons of yeast
and we've added one teaspoon of sugar
we're going to add another teaspoon of
sugar right into our bowl
and then we're going to add two
teaspoons of the best tasting salt in
the world
we actually import this salt from france
it's the marriage to our camo flour
you mentioned kamut tell us about kamu
what is kamu
yeah so kamoon is an ancient grain it's
never been genetically modified
it's 100 organic it's naturally enriched
it's known for taste texture
digestibility
and it actually has less glue so i want
to make sure we get the end of this and
then i want to really quick mention the
book too so
you add the yeast mixture and then you
add more water and you're just going to
keep adding some flour
until it starts coming away from the
bowl so easy
and then you would take it out on your
counter you knead it
just for a minute till it's nice soft
and elastic and then
this is how you shape it and these are
my french baguette pans and
my recipe tells you how to make four
mini and it's perfect that looks
amazing my mouth is watering you can get
that recipe and so many more
in your book what's the name of the book
again yeah so my new book it's called
for the love of commune it's all recipes
written for camus because
white wheat is a little it's a white
wheat and it's a little more dense
so i give you all these incredible
recipes cake cookies bread
because it replaces your all-purpose
flour and it's the taste
amazing on it looks amazing thank you so
much for the love of kamut
thank you